jacques took a submarine to the bottom
of the ocean and discovered an
underwater city
the starfish ruled the city this this is
fascinating there were 59 seahorses
there
which was
28 fewer than the number of starfish 28
fewer than the number i already used
that color
then
then the number
of starfish how many starfish how many
starfish were there so let's think about
the second sentence here so number of
seahorses is 28 fewer than the number of
starfish so we could write
we could write
number
of seahorses
sea horses
is 28 fewer than the number of starfish
so that means that this is going to be
equal to the number of starfish
number of starfish
starfish
minus 28 28 fewer than the number of
so
let me write that in blue
so if i have the number of starfish and
i get 2 and i go 28 fewer than that
that's going to be the number of
seahorses that's what they tell us the
number of seahorses there were 59
seahorses there which was 28 fewer than
the number of starfish and they actually
tell us what the number of sea horses is
it's 59 so we can write this as
we can write this as 59
is equal to the number of starfish
number
actually maybe i'll just draw well i'll
write it out starfish
the number of starfish
minus 28. minus
or another way to think about it is
there's 28 more starfish than sea horses
so we could rewrite this as saying well
whatever the number of sea horses are
whatever the number of seahorses are
they tell us there are 59 seahorses
there's going to be 28 more there's
going to be 28 more starfish and
whenever you do a problem like this it's
always a good idea just to do a check
just to say okay are there going to be
more starfish or more sea horses and
when you look at the the information
they give us they say there were 59
seahorses which was 28 fewer than the
number of starfish so if there are fewer
sea horses than starfish that tells you
there's going to be more starfish so it
makes sense if you want to go from the
seahorses the number of seahorses the
number of starfish you would add 28
because there's more starfish than sea
horses so now we just have to figure out
what 59 plus 28 is so let's do that
so 59 is five tens and nine ones
28 let's write the two tens in the tens
place and the eight ones in the ones
place we're going we're adding
we're going to go from the number of
seahorses and 28 more than that to get
to the number of starfish
so let's first go to the ones place nine
ones plus eight ones is seventeen ones
right the seven ones and one ten or you
can think of it as i carried the one but
all i did is i wrote the the 110 in 17 i
wrote that in the tens place
and now i can add 110 plus 5 10 plus 2
tens so let's see 1 plus 5 plus 2 is 8
8 tens
so the number of starfish
is
87. and you should always see if that
makes sense the number of starfish is
this right over here is 87. so there are
59 seahorses is that 28 fewer than 87
sure it is it's exactly 28 fewer in fact
that's what we used to solve this
question